[Musique]
approchez messieurs dames
entrez sous le grand chapitau venez voir
mon
spectacle découvrez un monde
[Musique]
nouveau vous pourrez voir la Voie Lactée
tomber doucement à vos pied et tous les
soleils de l'Afrique sortir d'une boîte
magique
avec les revers de ma je ferai
apparaître un lac puis avec deux ou
trois foule voici des ces et des
[Musique]
canards approchez messieurs dames
entrez sous le grand chapit venez voir
mon
spectacle découvrez un monde
nouveau
à l'intérieur de ce grand cirque d'un
coup de baguette magique je change
l'hiver en printemp je fais la pluie et
le temps plus de col blanche
s'en de mes manches vous verrez la poule
je D et bien d'autres choses
[Musique]
encore approchez messieurs dames
approchz
entrez sous le grand chapitau venez voir
mon
spectacle découvrez un monde nouveau
entrez sous le grand chapitau vous
pourrez voir dans mon Chapour
toutab géant en 3 secondes seulement
enfin le plus extraordinaire et ça
personne ne sait le faire j'invente une
couleur nouvelle et je l'ajoute à
l'arc-en-ciel approchez messieurs dames
approchez
entrez sous le grand chapitau venez voir
mon
spectacle découvrez un monde
nouveau mesdames et messieurs je vous
invite à vous joindre à notre grand
voyage ce soir à découvrir effectivement
un monde nouveau une ville de brume et
de mystère une Venise imaginaire oùon
rencontrerait artistes et paladins
Richard cochiante et Véronique
sonlequin et Colombine les bais de par
Collins je Manon et rond
venano et Alan Williams j andréard
italiens et français américain de
passage cette merveilleuse belle de la
nuit Emy Stewart approchez messieurs
dames
approchez
je